the weirdest project i had there i got
paid like a thousand dollars to edit
a series of books on um that were there
were sexy ghost stories
ghost stories i want to be very clear it
was the ghosts
that were sexy welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford this is an amazing story of
someone who found their passion and went
all in after it
meet sarah gerke founder of additive
integrity llc
sarah is focused on the
industrialization of additive
manufacturing
her journey with 3d printing began in
and in 2018 sarah founded additive
integrity llc
an independent editorial services
company targeting the 3d printing
industry
she is the managing editor of fabaloo on
the board of directors of women in 3d
printing
and looks forward to a more equitable
future for this industry
she is also a trained thespian and
former fiction editor
happily using both her english and
theater degrees in real life
sarah gurkey welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you where are you
calling from right now
awesome thanks so much for having me
michael i'm so happy to be
chatting with you from around cleveland
ohio today
i think you might be the very first
guest i have from cleveland ohio in over
450 episodes so i'm honored
and and you know i'm even more excited
about the fact that i have absolutely no
idea
about the things that we're going to
talk about i do care a lot about
diversity and inclusion which is going
to be a primary topic
but but but additive manufacturing
3d content i know practically nothing
and i'm so excited to
to pick your brain on it but even before
we get to that
your background is not even in that it's
more in you know
fiction editing medieval times you even
was working at a fair for many years
take me back to that time and we'll
progress with your journey
okay um so a lot of my background is in
english and theater to the point that
that's what my undergraduate degrees are
in i have
an english degree focusing a lot on
creative writing
and literary criticism my theater degree
focused on
directing for the stage i had a minor in
spanish
because liberal arts school you can just
have as many majors and minors as you
need
um so those are really you know what
ties that all together for me is
language and communication
so doing that on the stage doing it on
the page that's what i really love
so i've always been kind of a writer at
heart
but you know i didn't from a practical
standpoint
choose the most commonly seen as useful
degrees so i was even going to
get a master's degree in theater
directing but i graduated college in
2007.
i had to postpone my degree for a year
just
loan and visa issues i was going to go
to the uk for my master's
um but my visa had just a hold up on the
paperwork side so i postponed it then
the
recession hit in 2008. i saw another
friend who'd studied
for her master's in theater in ireland
and she came back and worked at the home
depot
for the next like five years so it's
just like maybe not
the time to intensively study
stage arts um
so i went full-time where i'd been
temping at the time which was a
manufacturing company
and it was just you know a time job it
was interesting i got
i worked as a receptionist but also in
accounting so i learned a lot about
invoicing
at the time and pressure components
which was what that company focused on
and then i got a job in 2008
actually using my english degree as an
editor
for industry research market research
and i worked there for the next six
years um i was writing and
editing studies on everything u.s world
and chinese markets
for everything from roofing and
construction
to bottle and drink packaging
i wrote studies on the cosmeceuticals
cosmetic surgery industries on the pet
health industry
and i also edited our company's first
study on the global 3d printing industry
and i was just like oh that's
interesting but it was just you know
another
thing i read about at work but six years
on i was looking for a new thing
and i was applying like literally
everywhere
i had hundreds of resumes out anything
that was editing or writing or stage or
some of it even
you know just kind of assistant work
because i was like i need to either be
like
super engaged in my next job or really
not engaged so i could focus on hobbies
and
you know pay the bills during the day so
this one
and that was actually when i started
fiction editing i got a freelance gig at
the time
editing romance novels of all things
but i was like you know what it's
editing fiction i've never read these
kinds of books but
i will accept several hundred dollars to
fix them
um so it was kind of a fun random thing
that i did for a few years and then you
know i even switched publishing houses
at one time and got to do more
general fiction it was just kind of a
weird
flip of these books i got to read um
the weirdest project i had there i got
paid like a thousand dollars to edit
a series of books on um that were there
were sexy ghost
stories sexy ghost stories
i want to be very clear it was the
ghosts that were sexy
i'm still uncomfortable
that's incredible and so at what point
what year are we now
after you've spent a few years editing
put you know things in and around sexy
ghost stories
so this is probably 2012 2013 2014-ish
and i was doing the editing as a
freelance gig for several years
and then in 2014 i saw
a job posting among the money that i was
responding to
that was a small new startup website
that was looking for an editor i was
like i could edit
news for you know an internet startup
why not and it turned out that website
was
called 3dprint.com and it was one of the
earlier sites
uh focusing on 3d printing i think it's
maybe the fourth oldest one out there
among kind of the primary
ones in the industry so i started
editing these stories
um at the time we were publishing close
to two dozen
a day like one to two dozen stories
daily uh and are these stories just
about
different projects that people are doing
with 3d printing and what's happening to
the industry
who's the audience for this yeah it was
really at the time it was kind of all
over the place because
that was during the 3d printing boom
kind of
it was really exciting around like 2013
to 2015-ish
that was when you might have seen all
these headlines like 3d print everything
a 3d printer in every house
you have a microwave you'll have a 3d
printer you can make anything at home
and so it's the super super over hyped
thing
which personally i love because that
hype
brought investors in and investors
investing in 3dprint.com made it big
enough to hire me
i was the second full-time employee so
it was
you know kind of this still young
undertaking
and then in 2015 the brothers who
founded the site
sold it and stepped out from the
editorial side so i stepped up then as
the editor-in-chief
and that was september 2015
and in october of that year i went to my
very first
3d printing event and that's when i got
to talk to the people i'd been reading
and writing about for so long
the people making things because it's
not just you know
tchotchkes and yoda heads there was a
lot of medical
a lot of art a lot of these really cool
complex
ideas that people were making real and
so as soon as i went to the show and i
met them i
just kind of had this you know come to
career moment
because i was like oh this isn't a job
this is a career for me like i love this
look at the passion of these people look
what they're able to do
and i get to tell their stories so in
this way it was
this really cool serendipity like
somehow this industry found me and chose
me to help tell its stories
in a way so i built up that team i built
up all of
the content we were doing i pivoted our
focus a lot
toward industrial because there are
these like
million dollar huge machines you know
there are these little bitty desktop
printers that cost a couple hundred
bucks that can do cool things
but what caught me is the industrial
side and
you know you've got these huge things
that you can put on a manufacturing
floor next to a cnc
machine or you know all of these
traditional pieces of equipment
and together they're just so incredible
and can make
make new things make new things better
and
so i you know i brought my tiny little
head to show you
so i was 3d scanned at a show
in germany and they that company 3d
printed me
in metal so this is me in titanium in
titanium unbelievable so who doesn't
need their own like
monopoly piece of their head right i
love it now tell me sorry a little bit
about
tell me a little bit about your
relationship with with the industry
because one of the things that i'm
most interested in when what you're
saying here this
idea this concept that you're coming in
is a creative writing
english major you're going through
different publications you're writing
you're editing sexy ghost stories among
among other things
but but then you you sort of fall into
this opportunity
to not just edit a lot of these stories
but but really get engulfed in this
industry and you actually find
passion in uncovering this industry
it's something that you know a lot of
people in the tech industry a lot of
engineers don't even yet understand
right so what how is this how does this
relationship form
and sort of what do you learn about
yourself through those years
well it was so interesting because for
me the biggest learning process was
going to see everything
going to manufacturing facilities which
somehow in my life became
fun and exciting like yes i get to go on
a shop floor
i got made fun of on twitter because i
was pumped a few years ago to go to this
little town
in the united kingdom and go to a
manufacturing facility opening
and i was like yeah i am actually
excited about this that's that's where i
am in life right now
um but i got so into all these things
and like talking to the
passionate people doing these talking to
people making prosthetics for kids
talking to people making these
incredible pieces of
art and these really boring components
as well like that's when it really
becomes real
and so i got so tied into all of this in
i left the site i'd been working for and
made my own company and so through that
i work with
babylon now as their managing editor
it's another one of the very oldest
sites
in the industry we focus a lot on
analysis and getting
into the insightful aspects but i also
work directly with the industry
so for the last you know two and a half
years i've been
writing pieces for companies i've been
writing white papers and blogs i've been
doing case studies and digging into what
they specifically do and getting to know
these technologies better
and i started working more closely with
a non-profit
called women in 3d printing so i'm on
the board you're on the board
right i am so i've been
doing that since 2018 and we introduced
the diversity for additive manufacturing
reports
because one of the big things in the
industry is designed for additive
manufacturing
so that dfam um you know in the shoulder
is really familiar
in my industry and so we took dfam to
mean diversity
for am as well because that's something
else that should be important to how we
build it up
so tell me a little bit about where we
are today with this industry from your
perspective
both in terms of the diversity aspect
but but also in terms of
what you're observing you know in in
this industry and where we're headed and
why
how why why you choose to channel a lot
of your energy to to this very important
topic of course but but you still choose
to spend a lot of time on it
as you're as you're still engulfed in
this industry so so tell me a little bit
about
the why it it happened really
organically right
um additive manufacturing is an advanced
manufacturing technology
and so it's right at this intersection
of tech and manufacturing
but both of those industries both of
those cornerstones that
come together here are historically
really male dominated
and beyond that historically very white
male dominated
and you know tech
is a little bit of a newer younger
hipper kind of thing
and then so 3d printers kind of this
young hip
manufacturing sector which means you
know we're
necessarily getting that younger
workforce happening
and you know we see kind of just the way
things evolved naturally anyway
but the younger generation
tends to be a little bit more diverse
but there is still that backbone
of this is what tech looks like this is
what manufacturing looks like
and it wasn't very long into doing what
i do and traveling for it that i would
look around and be like oh
i am the only woman in this room
and you know i'm sitting at the table
i'm the only woman at the table
but then it really got to me too that
i'm the only woman at this table and i'm
not
really even in the industry like it's
not even my table
i'm here to talk about this but no one
at these other tables looks like me
and for my colleagues of color and my
other colleagues in different minorities
you know if i'm sitting there as a white
woman like no one else here looks like
me
it's even less that for them you know
and so
realizing that complete disparity in
just what the room looks like
and then you go to the manufacturing
facility and you're like you know what
all of the people in here they're not
that demographic we see presenting
they're not the demographic we see in
the c-suite
we have everyone here we have people
from all gender representations we have
people from
all kinds of backgrounds all kinds of
ethnicities all kinds of educations
all on the shop floor together but
you know how do we make that more
visible
and how do we make more students feel
like this could be an industry they want
to go into
when they don't see themselves in it
already
because there's that whole idea of if
you can see it you can be it
and start women in 3d printing we talk
about role models a lot and if you can
see her you can be her
and so we're encouraging people who are
doing it already
you know be seen do it talk about it
if you want to get into it become her
you know
we need we still need those people
blazing those trails and right now
the end estimate is 15 percent
one five percent women in the industry
and that is less in technical roles and
that is less
as you get into executive roles so
you know the highest percentages of
women are in marketing and
communications
i've worked with a lot of other female
journalists but
when it comes to the tech roles when it
comes to the ceos the ctos the cfos
they're few and far between but they're
also they are there
um it's more than people think with
women in 3d printing we put on our first
conference
at the start of this year just in
january we had
an all female speakers agenda we had 147
female speakers
over five tracks in two days wow
and we had more than 200 speaker
submissions
initially like picking pairing it down
to 147 was so
hard for those of us on the executive
committee
because there there really are that many
qualified
expert speakers in these demographics
people are just like oh
we can't find any women guess this
panel's all men we're like no they're
there let's here they are you're gonna
tell me they're not there
here we go like i will never again
believe someone who says
oh i can't find a woman to speak really
because we found 200 just
with an open speaker submission call
that that's amazing and i think that you
know a lot of people talk about
diversity a lot of people talk about you
know
lead by doing but at the end actually
you know getting it done and actually
showing
you know you're not saying here yeah
just fine go find them yeah they're
there you're saying we found them we did
the hard part
we've proven we we've gone out in source
now
here you go no more excuses i think
that's you know not just you know but
all
obviously never as an inclusion but in
anything in any
place that needs to be that needs a
needle to be moved
uh that's the way to go especially when
when the
when the people you're trying to
convince are convinced of something else
and so and so it it makes a lot of sense
to me
sorry before we go on to the to the fun
questions i i want to ask you one more
thing that has been in the back of my
mind
and that is this idea of going from you
know
fiction creative writing to something
very technical
to telling very technical stories in an
industry that you don't know and this is
i think very
very you know specifically interesting
for people that are are thinking about
shifting directions people that are
thinking about you know
trying out something new but it's really
scary especially you know
this you know very technical industry
what was that experience like for you
it was definitely a learning curve um
but really my background being so broad
helped me so much
especially you know again i touched on
having had a spanish minor so
translation
is a key thing of what i do as well as
theater we think about
translating from page to stage so
there's always that aspect of that so i
see a lot of what my job is
as translating engineering to readable
because if you ask an engineer to write
something out you know in paragraphs
it might not be something you are
following
super easily um so that's what i do you
know i take what they say and i
i've learned to speak engineering and
i've learned the questions to ask
and the best thing i can say is you know
just
listen listen and learn and you have to
go and humble
to something new but you also have to
have that eye toward
opportunity because i i jumped um
when i took my first job in this
industry it was
a crap shoot it was just i guess i do
this now
and you know let's try it out thankfully
my husband was super supportive he was
just like
try it if it doesn't work we'll figure
it out together
and it worked you know it's not anywhere
i would have foreseen right now there
are bachelors masters and phd programs
in additive manufacturing there are
internships there are associate's
degrees there's workforce training
there's like girl scouts introduced to
3d printing badge
so it's really growing up but when i was
in school when i was the girl scout when
i was in college
these degrees weren't there so all of
this is growing so fast so it's
opportunity and flexibility are really
the most important things just being
adaptable
being willing to take a risk sometimes
with your career
and like if that's what interests you
and it seems like a viable thing and
this technology
is you know there's a validated industry
upholding it there's a foundation there
it's not just like
right oh let's go into this digital
widget industry
but prefer and you know you have to make
sure that you're sourcing
appropriately but it was it was a jump
and it's it did help me to have that
broad liberal arts background honestly
wonderful sarah thank you so much for
coming on and sharing with me
and you know this wonderful journey and
i really appreciate you being so
generous of your time and i know that
you're very busy and you have to go soon
but i have a few
a few short quick questions for you are
you ready
hit me all right number one favorite
subject in school
creative writing of course makes a lot
of sense
one of your favorite role models
throughout your life
real or fictional see this is the
hardest one for me and
i know you told me ahead of time you
would ask it and i kept like hoping you
wouldn't
still somehow um
because i just i don't have a clear
answer so i'm going to go fictional
and i'm going to go with the doctor from
doctor who
i love i'm a huge fan can't really see
it right now i have a tardis tattooed
right here
wow my office
that the parts you can't see have doctor
who wall art everywhere
um anyway the doctor is
always growing always learning always
humble always helping
always changing always adapting the 13th
doctor
is also excellent i think she is very
adaptable to this new world this new
generation
and every new doctor brings something
new
but it's always the spirit of the doctor
which is helping
i too love the show and i recommend
everybody who who
who wants to get engulfed in a different
reality completely
check it out it's really wonderful and i
agree with you that this changing of
doctors
well initially i was very you know
thrown back by it i was like i'm not
sure that i
that i want my main character to to
change every few years but it's actually
it's quite it's quite amazing and the
last question
three words you would use to describe
yourself
see optimistic
hopeful i define those differently by
the way
optimistic hopeful and exhausted
i love it i have a one-year-old so
that's that last is really just a way of
life
i love it sarah thank you very very much
this was wonderful thank you for taking
the time to to speak with me and to
share with your
your journey i think it's so relevant
today and so relevant for so many people
so thank you very much
and stay safe and stay healthy thanks
michael you too thanks for having me
you